What specifically did the coaches or the
players change between 2012 and 2013
that allowed you guys to win the second
time what specifically was changed the
messaging I don't care how good you are
you always have to introduce chaos into
the system it gets you out of your
comfort zone as a team and as an
individual and it makes you re examine
how you do things Pat Ry the great
general manager of the heat he always
used to say you can't win with 12 milk
drinkers all right it's okay to throw a
guy who drinks Jack in there
right you have to throw in some chaos to
keep people on their toes and so no
matter how good you are you have to
introduce chaos Controlled Chaos just to
keep people on their toes and and when
you stop doing that that's when the
competition gains on you